une partie d'une mâchoire d'une baleine
ou une statue représentant le mythe
d'andromède cette petite salle fourmis
de collections d'archéologie de
botanique d'anatomie et de préhistoire
dans cette vitrine et celle ci les
collections de prison on va les
collections de paléontologie
des pièces rares inédite jamais présenté
au public
elle appartenait à la famille de luynes
propriétaire pendant plus de trois
siècles du château de dampierre
nous sommes dans la pièce principale qui
la grande pièce qui fait à peu près 400
mètres carrés qui entouré de vitrines et
au centre il ya des vitrines également
la majorité de la collection présente
des minéralogie dans cette pièce
ce sont d une collection de pierres de
toutes origines météorite pierres
précieuses fossiles plus de 6000
exemplaires de pierre sont présentés
dans cette salle également une
collection de zoologie on a des petits
moments forts on va belles collections
entomologiques reptiles poissons et
aussi animaux sauvages viennent
compléter ses collections et visites
guidées se font sur réservation maximum
cinq personnes par visite pour respecter
les consignes sanitaires seulement une
endroit d'une grande grande richesse
dont toutes les pièces
vraiment mis en valeur on apprend
vraiment sûr sur la recherche
scientifique au 19e et même avant la
collection de pierres de minéraux est
vraiment extraordinaire
j'imaginais pas qu'il y avait autant de
choses différentes dans le monde
ce cabinet de curiosités seulement
ouvert pendant les vacances de la
toussaint une période propice pour
inviter les familles la présentation
exceptionnelle que nous avons
aujourd'hui elle se fait évidemment par
les vacances de la toussaint puisque on
recherche un peu le mystérieux et donc
là on est en plein dedans et puis aussi
elle correspond à la fin des travaux qui
ont été réalisés par le propriétaire
pour sécuriser cet espace cette aile du
château nommé el d'astrée était en train
de s'effondrer
il fallait donc là sécurisé pour sauver
la collection le billet d'entrée pour un
adulte est de 20 euros